احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه تقدمها لكم ميسون وهد عنوان وحيد
في هذه الساعه الاخباريه وهي الاحتجاجات
الخاصه في اسرائيل والمشهد كيف سيكون بعد
اقاله نتنياهو لوزير الدفاع اذا بعد رفضه
التعديلات القضائيه
نتنياهو يقيل وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي من
منصبه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم افاده وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه
ان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتانياهو استدعى
وزير الدفاع قبل اقالته وقال انه فقد
الثقه فيه بعد ان عمل ضد الحكومه وضد
الائتلاف الحاكم جاء هذا في وقت تتهم فيه
المعارضه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
بزعزعه استقرار البلاد وبانه سيدفع البلاد
الى الهاويه وبانه يهدد الامن القومي ايضا
وفي اولى ردود الفعل من الداخل الاسرائيلي
على قرار اقاله نيسانياهو لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي من منصبه قال حزب العمال
الاسرائيلي
يشكل خطرا على امن اسرائيل فيما اكد
ائتلاف الوحده الوطنيه الاسرائيليه ان
نتنياهو مصمم على القاء اسرائيل في
الهاويه بدوره اوضح الذي كان يشغل منصبا
نتنياهو ان تصرفات الاخير تهدد الامن
القومي
من القدس ينضم الي مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي زياد اهلا بك معنا الامور يبدو انها
ايله للتصعيد وهذا تحول دراماتيكي كما
تصفه دائما انت زياد باي ازمه تحصل هل
يمكن ان تشرح لنا ماذا يجري الان هذه
الاحتياجات الى اين مثلا نتوقع في الساعات
المقبله
بنيامين نتنياهو ميسون صب الزيت على النار
باقاله يو ار جالنت وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي هذا الامر اشعل المظاهرات بشكل
كبير في تل ابيب هناك اغلاق للتورق
الرئيسيه لمسار ايلون وهناك نوع من
المواجهات ايضا قباله يعني مكتب او منزل
نتنياهو في القدس الغربيه هناك مظاهره هذا
كله مجرد بدايه لما سنشهده طوال هذا
الاسبوع عمليا على المقلب الاخر الواضح
ايضا من خلال خطوه نتنياهو بانه مصمم على
تمرير التشريعات التي تسميها المعارضه
العريضه في الشارع الاسرائيلي الانقلاب
على نظام القضاء في اسرائيل لا استبعد غدا
حتى منتصف الليل ان يتم اقرار القانون
الذي يقضي بالسيطره الائتلاف بشكل كبير
على لجنه تعيين القضاه وهو الامر الذي كان
اخرج الناس في الاساس الى الشوارع بهذا
المعنى الامور وصلت الى طريق مسدود بين
الجانبين والى صدام واضح في الشارع قبل
قليل بيان مشترك من لبيد وجانس يعني
المعارضه في اسرائيل قال فيه ان نتنياهو
تخطى الخط الاحمر وعلى النواب في الليكود
الانشقاق عنه
والانضمام الى الاحتجاجات عمليا
هل هذا الامر ممكن ان يحصل هل نحن امام
مشهد من الممكن ان نتابع او ان نشهد
انشقاقات
وبالتالي هذا سيضعف حزب نتانياهو هل سيحصل
ذلك هل نتوقع ذلك
يسيطر بشكل كبير ميسون على الحزب الليكود
يفعل في هناك ما يشاء عمليا يعني بالكاد
تجدين مجموعه صغيره من اربعه او خمسه عاده
يشكلون نواه لمعارضه داخليه في حزب الكود
ولكن الان بعد غالنت هناك
الذي هو ايضا رئيس لجنه اللجنه البرلمانيه
للخارجيه والامن وهو اعتقد في طريقه ايضا
للاقاله من هذا المنصب لا يستطيع ان
يتنياهو ان يقيله من منصب نائب لان فقط
يقيل وزراء لكن غدا تحدّ نتنياهو غدا
استدعى الى لجنه الخارجيه والامن كي يشرح
لها لماذا خرج وحذر من ان خطه نتنياهو
تشكل خطرا امنيا دائما على اسرائيل
بالنسبه للوضع الداخلي تفكك الجيش
الاسرائيلي
العصيان المدني العسكري عفوا من سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي اليوم كان هناك تقرير في
القناه الثانيه عشره غير مسبوق نحو 40
طيارا في الاحتياط قالوا بشكل واضح بانهم
عمليا لا يذهبون الان الى التدريبات طبعا
ان لم يذهب التيار الى التدريبات اكثر من
شهر يصبح غير عملاته من ناحيه الاداء لا
يمكن ارساله في مهام قالوا انه اذا استمر
نتنياهو في هذا التشريع عمليا
سيستطيع ان ينسى ان يشاركوا في قصف منشات
ايران النوويه هذا امر غير مسبوق ان يصدر
على ضباط في السلاح الجو الاسرائيلي بهذا
الشكل ولكن الواضح ايضا على المقلب الاخر
بان نتنياهو ماضي الى اخر الشوط هناك الان
تحذيرات كثيره لان عمليا جلنت لم يصوت ضد
الخطه لم يعارض الخطه علنا كل ما قاله ان
هناك خطوره امنيه مت عن الوضع الحالي داخل
اسرائيل داخليا بسبب تفكك محتمل للجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي يشكل محطه الاجماع منذ
انشاء اسرائيل والامر الاخر قراءه الخارج
لما يحدث في الداخل جلنت اوضح في الدوائر
المختلفه بان هناك تاكل في الرضع
الاسرائيلي في مواجهه الخارج بسبب ان ما
يحدث يرتسم
ضعف والمهم في كل ما قاله ليس انه قاله
فقط كراي شخصي نقل اجماعا داخل المؤسستين
الامنيه والعسكريه في اسرائيل فهل على
نتنياهو الان ان يقيل رئيس الموساد ورئيس
الشباب ورئيس هيئه الاركان في اسرائيل لان
الثلاثه يتحدثون يعني بالكلمات ذاتها
تقريبا نعم زياد اسمح لي ان تبقى معي
ساعود اليك بعد قليل لمتابعه المجريات
والتطورات على الارض ولكن الان ساذهب الى
القدس مع شلون المحلل سياسي سيد شلومو هذا
المشهد وهذا هذه الاقاله
يبدو بانها اشعلت الاحتجاجات اكثر مما
كانت مشتعله في الايام الماضيه كيف يمكن
ان نشرح هذا القرار الذي نتنياهو وماذا
ممكن ان نتوقع من قرارات لاحقه في الساعات
المقبله
لنبدا بالاحتجاجات فور اعلان القرار
باقوله وزير الدفاع
اعلنت قياده
الوزارات بانها تعارض مثل هذا القرار
وانها تدعو المتظاهرين الى الخروج الى
شوارع وهكذا تم في غدون دقائق عده
الانطلاق المتظاهرين في كل منا تل ابيب
وحيفا والقدس والمشاهدها الان في القنوات
الاسرائيليه مباشره حيث
بدون ان تكون القوات الشرطه على استعداد
مما ادى الى اغلاق الشوارع العامه في تل
ابيب وايضا الى اقتحام في الساعات الاخيره
الحواجز حول اهدار
نتنياهو في مدينه القدس هذه هي
الاجراءات الوقائيه التي تتخذها الشرطه
في هذه الساعه
بمجال المتظاهرين وتفريقهم ولكن هناك على
غرام ما تم امس تمتنع الشرطه في هذه
الساعه من المواجهات لكي
تخوفات من ان تتحول هذه الاحتياجات الى
عنف لان البعض يعتبر بانه هي مساله وقت
والامور ستفلت من زمام يعني زمام الامور
ستفلت من يدي كل المؤسسات الامنيه في
اسرائيل
اعتقد بان
ما نسب الى نتنياهو من تصريح المساء اليوم
بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع بانه يجب مواجهه
العصيان بالقوه اي معناه دفع المتظاهرين
الى اتخاذ اجراءات متشدده ضد القوات
الامنه ضد الشرطه والى التظاهر والى ابداء
ارائهم بكل عنف واعتقد ان بعد
ثلاثه اشهر من المظاهرات السلميه نوعا ما
الذي كانت سننتقل لا سمح الله الان الى
تصعيد في الحته المظاهرات خاصه للرد على
تحدي
على تحدي القرار باقاله وزير الدفاع على
تحدي القرار
الحزبيه داخل الحزب الديكود
باقاله وزير الدفاع هل
نتانياهو يتحدى المؤسسات الامنيه
والعسكريه لانه جلنط هو لا يمثل نفسه هو
يمثل مؤسسات امنيه وعسكريه
وما قاله غالنت هو يعبر عن راي هذه
المؤسسات
اعتقد ان قرار نتنياهو باقاله وزير الدفاع
هو ايضا تحدي
للجيش وايضا
للازرعه الامن المختلفه حيث الرساله التي
مررها من جراء الاكاله هي انه يجب عليهم
الانشغال في المواضيع الامنيه والعسكريه
وعدم اقام المواضيع السياسيه في الشؤون
التي
ونحن نتحدث معك هناك اخبار عاجله وخبر
عاجله على شاشه العربيه بان المتظاهرين
يتوجهون لمنزل نتنياهو للاحتجاج ضد اقاله
وزير الدفاع لرفضه الاصلاح القضائي اذا
المتظاهرون سيتوجهون لمنزل نتنياهو
للاحتجاج ضد هذه الاقاله لوزير الدفاع
هذا التحدي من قبل نتنياهو اتجاه موضوع
القضاء وخاصه بانه هو متهم يعني امام هذا
القضاء
الى اين سيؤدي هذا التحدي خاصه في ظل هذه
الاحتياجات خاصه في ظل هذه ردود الافعال
من قبل المعارضه من قبل المسؤولين من قبل
مؤسسات امنيه
هل نتوقع ان تعود او يعود نتنياهو عن هذا
القرار عن موضوع التعديلات ام على العكس
سيبقى مستمرا فيه الى النهايه
للاسف سيستمر ولكن عوده الى التحدي مع
الجهاز الفضائي في مساء اليوم
الوكلاء نتنياهو محمول نتنياهو رد
بالنيابه عنه الى المحكمه حول الاستئنافات
التي قدمت للمحكمه بالنسبه لتصرفه وايضا
بالنسبه
لم يخالف تضارب الصفاق تضارب المصالح قال
نتنياهو عند لسانه
بانه ليس للمحكمه صلاحيه بالتدخل في هذا
الموضوع ليس كرونيا لان الكنيسه هي التي
شرعت القوانين ليس للمحكمه صلاحيه لتجاوز
صلاحيات الكنيست او التعدي على صلاحيه
الكنيست ولذلك موقف المحكمه العليا وهو
مردود ولا شان لها في شؤون السياسيه
المدنيه هيعتقد بان هذا هو بمثابه تحدي من
قبل رئيس الحكومه من قبل الرئيس السلطه
التنفيذيه للسلطه القضائيه وهذا رد لا
يسهل على الامر بل يعقد الامور اكثر
نعم السيد سلومو ابقى معي اسمح لي ان اعود
واذكر ببعض الاخبار العاجله التي وردت على
شاشه العربيه قبل ان انتقل قبل ان انتقل
الى دكتورنا مصري اذا الشرطه الاسرائيليه
تمنع المحتاجين من الوصول لبيت نتنياهو
وكنا ذكرنا بانه
المتظاهرين يتوجهون لمنزل نتنياهو
للاحتجاج على اقاله وزير الدفاع لرفض
الاصلاح القضائي بالنسبه لحزب العمل
الاسرائيلي كان لديه ايضا بعض المواقف
يقول بان نتنياهو يشكل خطرا على امن
اسرائيل وزعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يعيد
لبيديا يقول ايضا بان نتنياهو يهدد الامن
وبالنسبه لهذه الحشود فهي اغلقت الطريق
السريع الرئيسي في تل ابيب احتجاجا على
اقاله وزير الدفاع وهناك دعوات لاضراب
شامل غدا الاثنين ساذهب الان الى دكتور
مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه
العبريه ينضم الي من القدس دكتور مئر يبدو
بانه نتنياهو في هذه الاقاله اشعل
الاحتياجات اكثر ما هي كانت مشتعله وهناك
توقعات بان تزداد هذه الاحتجاجات هذا
التحول الان
ووصولا الى اقاله وزير الدفاع الى اي مشهد
سياخذ اسرائيل في الساعه اللاحقه
نعم شكرا لكم على الاستضافه تحياتي لك يا
استاذي الكريم
انا اعتقد انه لا يوجد خيار اخر في الواقع
امام السيد نتنياهو وحكومته الا ان يقوم
بتجميد الاجراءات المتابعه
الذهاب الى حوار جاد ومباشر مع المعارضه
وفقا للمبادره التي تقدم بها الرئيس انا
لا اعتقد هناك من مؤشرات دكتور مصري عندما
يقيل وزير الدفاع يعني في هذه الساعات
الماضيه هل هناك من اي مؤشر بانه نتنياهو
من الممكن ان يقوم بهذه الخطوه التي تتفضل
بها حضرتك
هناك اكثر من نقطه اول نقطه
اول نقطه لا انا لست متاكدا انه يتاولا هو
ليس شخص عادي داخل الكود هو نائب في موقع
متقدم على قائمه ان اتوقع ان يلحق به
ويدعم موقفه اكثر من نائب داخل حسب
وبالتالي لا انا لست متاكدا بان الكود سوف
تكون لدي او الائتلاف الحاكم الذي يتزعمه
سوف يكون لديها الاغلبيه النيابيه التي
تسمح له بتمرير مشاريع القوانين
المذكوره النقطه الثانيه النقطه الثانيه
هو انه لو تم تنبير المرحله الاولى من هذه
المشاريع لان الحديث عن 11 مشروع قانون
تحت عنوان الاصلاح القضائي المشروع
القانون الاول الاول لو لم تمريره المحكمه
العليا لن لن تقرب دستوريته وبالتالي فان
الرئيس لن يوقع على
المشروع وهذا وفقا للعرف الدستوري القائم
في اسرائيل
دكتور مصري
نعم دستوريه وحينئذ سوف يكون امام الحكومه
خيارات او العدول عن المشروع
وهذا ما انا ارجحه او التحدي الشرعيه وهذا
ما ينادي به وزير العدل السيد ليفين عراب
المشروع الذي يقول لو اصطدمنا بالمحكمه
فسوف نمرر بالقوه المشروع وهنا سوف تخرج
الحكومه عن الاطار الشرعيه وبالتالي هذا
قد
يصعد من الموقف وانا اعتقد انهم من ان
يؤدي الى عزل رئيس الوزراء
والاطاحه بالحكومه من قبل المحكمه المحكمه
العليا من قبل القضاء القضاء لكن لا اعتقد
سوف يجعل الامور تصل الى هذا الحاضر اعتقد
انه هناك
حد معين سوف سوف يقف عنده ولكن البعض
يعتبر بانه فقد الاتصال بالواقع يعني
عندما يقوم على الرغم من كل هذه
الاحتجاجات وعلى الرغم من كل هذه
المطالبات بالرجوع عن هذه التعديلات قام
باقاله وزير الدفاع الذي يعني لديه
يمثل مؤسسات عسكريه وامنيه وهي التي ايضا
رافضه لهذه التعديلات
نعم هو لا ينظر الى الامور هكذا هو وزير
الدفاع في اسرائيل هو ليس هو منصب سياسي
وليس منصب عسكري هو يعني مصادفه السيد هو
رجل عسكري ولكن كان من الممكن ان لا يكون
كذلك وبالتالي هو ليس على راس المؤسسه
العسكري بين الجيش
ولكن نقصد بان ما عبر به وزير الدفاع هو
راي المؤسسه الامنيه ايضا والمؤسسه
العسكريه يعني ونحن نتابع ايضا هناك يعني
زميلنا زياد كان تحدث بانه هناك عصيان
عسكري هناك اربعين طيار لا يذهبون الى
التدريبات مثلا
فهناك حتى المعارضه تقول هناك خطر اني
داهم
نعم صحيح لا شك في هذا انا اعتقد اولا
الاشكاليه ليس في عدد الطيارين 37 تيار او
الضباط الذين يتظاهرون وهم حصلوا على
موافقه من القضاء العسكري قبل ان يقوموا
بالتظاهر وكذلك الذين لم يشاركوا في
تدريباتهم لم يشاركوا في تدريبات اختياريه
اذا الامور تسير حتى هذه اللحظه في اطار
الشرعيه والحديثه عن عدد ضئيل من الضباط
مقارنه بالضباط الهزيمه هم في الخدمه لا
اعتقد ان هذا قد يؤثر على اداء الجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه في اسرائيل ولكن لا شك
في انه الخطوره هي تكمن في رمزيه ما يحدث
وهو
اقحام الجيش في قضايا سياسيه محاوله تسييس
المسؤولين عن الجيش وكذلك تسييس القضاه
وتسييف الشرطه والحديث عن انه هناك قضايا
ثريين ويجب ادخال قضاه لكوديين او يمينيين
حتى يكون هناك توازن وهذا كلام رئيس
الوزراء وهذه السابقه منذ متى كان الضابط
ينتمي الى حزب او كان القاضي ينتمي الى
الى طرف سياسي معين وبالتالي انا اعتقد
مره اخرى كلما نعيش اليوم هو نتيجه مباشره
لسلوك وخطاب الحكومه ولكن هو هناك فرصه
واحده امام الحكومه انا اعتقد وهو القيام
باسم المصلحه العليا للبلاد بتجميد
الاجراءات المتابعه والذهاب الى حوار جاد
مع المعرض ربما ان تكون هناك
ولكن ايضا
سنبر العجله التي ترد على شاشه العربيه
المعارضه الاسرائيليه تدعو اعضاء حزب
اللكود بعدم القبول بمنصب وزير الدفاع
وكانت قلما يقبل بهذا المنصب يجلب العار
لنفسه ايضا قالت المعارضه الاسرائيليه لا
ينبغي ان يكون امن البلاد لعبه سياسيه
وايضا هذه ابرز النقاط التي تناولها
البيان
للمعارضه الاسرائيليه التي يحمل هذا
البيان مسؤوليه يحمل نتنياهو طبعا مسؤوليه
تهديد امن اسرائيل وكانت الشرطه ايضا منذ
قليل تشتبك مع محتجين يريدون الوصول الى
بيت نتانياو بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع ساذهب
مجددا الى زميلنا زياد حلبي زياد ما
الجديد ما هي ابرز ردود الفعل والوضع على
الارض وضع الاحتياجات هل الاعداد تزيد
هذا صحيح كما اسلفتي قبل قليل هناك
متظاهرين الان في محيط منزل نتنياهو في
القدس الغربيه بالاضافه الى المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات في تل ابيب وقد نجح
المتظاهرون والمحتاجون كما في مرات سابقه
في قطع المسار الاساسي ايلون في لبضع
الوقت ايضا وسط اسرائيل هذا الامر كان
متوقعا وسترى هذا الاسبوع كل الاسبوع
سيكون على وقع هذه المظاهرات اسبوع الشلل
هكذا يسميه المحتجون اي ادخال اسرائيل في
حال شلل في كل الاماكن في تل ابيب وفي
القدس الغربيه وفي كل الاماكن في محاوله
للضغط ايضا على الائتلاف في خصوص
التشريعات لكن على ما يبدو ان لم تكن
مفاجات بان نتنياهو الائتلاب سيحاولان حتى
غدا لن ننتظر كثيرا تمرير
ربما البند الذي اخرج الناس في الاساس من
قضيه السيطره على لجنه تعيين القضاه في
اسرائيل لن يكون مفاجئا ان يحاول تمريره
غدا حتى منتصف الليل وعمليا
تتحدث عن استقاله قنصل تل ابيب في نيويورك
احتجاجا على اقاله وزير الدفاع اذا حسب
رويترز هناك استقاله لقنصل تل ابيب في
نيويورك احتجاجا على اقاله وزير الدفاع
تفضل زياد
[موسيقى]
نعم هذا صحيح
وعمليا الان كما يرد ايضا من المعلومات
قد
يقدم التماسا للمحكمه العليا ضد اقالته
يعني هذا ليس مؤكدا ولكن هناك دراسه في
محيط غاند جالنت عفوا
لتقديم هذا الالتماس وان كان غير متبع
عمليا في خلال 48 ساعه ستصبح هذه الاقاله
نافذه للتذكير فقط نتنياهو هذا وزير
الدفاع الثالث الذي يقيله نتنياهو عمليا
كان اقل اسحاق مردخاي قبلا ومشيعه لون لكن
في ظروف تختلف حقيقه عمليا الماخذ الاساسي
للمعارضه الاسرائيليه كما يقول اركانها
على ما حصل اليوم هو ان جالنت عمليا لم
يصوت ضد هذه الخطه ولم يعلن بانه ضد الخطه
كل ما فعله انه طلب ولكن الموقف لقنصر
اسرائيل في نيويورك الذي يقول لا يمكنني
ان اخدم بحكومه يقودها نتانياهو اذا قنصل
اسرائيل في نيويورك يقول بانه لا يمكنه ان
يخدم بحكومه يقودها نتنياهو اليك زياد من
جديد
[تصفيق]
خارج ايضا
سيطلعهم على ما يتداول داخل المؤسسه
الامنيه والعسكريه في اسرائيل كما سمعها
سمعها عمليا من رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
ربما المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه في
اسرائيل اكثر ما تخشاه هو
اتساع دائره العصيان العسكري لانه كما
قلنا الجيش الاسرائيلي في اسرائيل هو محط
اجماع تقليدي منذ انشاء اسرائيل وبالتالي
هذا يبدو دراماتيكيا ما يحدث
بخصوص
قضايا رفض الخدمه وما الى ذلك
وهناك ايضا من يتساءل كيف سينج ولكن هناك
اخبار عاجله ترد الان البيت الابيض خليكم
ما يجري في اسرائيل بعد اقاله وزير الدفاع
وكان منذ قليل اعلام اسرائيل اذا حدث عن
ان المحتجين يخترقون الحواجز المؤديه
لمنزل نتنياهو زياد ساعود اليك ولكن دعنا
نتحدث مع اش لون المحلل السياسي الذي ايضا
هو معنا من القدس لنتحدث عن هذا هذه
الاستقاله من قبل قنصل اسرائيل في نيويورك
هل نحن امام مشهد انشقاقات
يجب الاشاره هنا بان قنصل اسرائيل في
نيويورك هو تعجين سياسي من قبل الحكومه
السابقه حكومه العقيد وهو ينتمي ايضا الى
حكومه لافيد وحصل على هذا المنصب ذو عوضا
عن عدم تعيينه وزيرا في حكومته لذلك هذا
على خلفيه سياسيه محضى اي انه يعارض حكومه
لاسباب سياسيه واضحه من حضرتك
لا نتوقع ان يكون هناك انشقاقات او
استقالات من هيئات دبلوماسيه اخرى من دول
اخرى
سبق للاحزاب الائتلافيه في كل حكومه في
اسرائيل هناك حصه من التعيينات
الدبلوماسيه لا تتجاوز
العشره او 12 وظيفه
دبلوماسيه على مستوى الكسن او سفراء اخر
من استقالت من منصب السفيره الاسرائيليه
في باريس كانت قبل حوالي في الشهر الماضي
وهي كانت وليده تعيين من قبل الحكومه
السابقه واعلنت ان رفضها لمواصله تمثيل
اسرائيل تحتل حكومه لذلك اعتقد بان
استقاله
القنصل في نيويورك هي امتدادا لرغبه اولئك
الذين تم تعيينهم سياسيا بالاستقاله خاصه
وان القنصل فيه نيويورك نشر قبل اسبوعين
مقال ضد حكومه اليهود
على اثرها الى القدس الايداع موقفه واعتقد
بانه
قدم الاستقرار قبل ان يواجه اللجنه
التحقيق طيب طيب
ما مدى خطوره يعني حسب المراقبين يقولون
بانه نتنياهو سيمضي بتشريع قانون القضاء
ويريد ان يسيطر على اللجنه التعيين القضاه
ان حصل ذلك ما مدى خطوره ذلك عليكم على
اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
ماضي في التشريع واعتقد انه حتى ليله ما
بين الاربعاء والخميس سيتم تشريع هذا
القانون قانون الاصلاح القضائي ولكن في
اقتراحهم مساء اليوم
بمثابه اقتراح وسط فهو قرر بانه
تشكيل هيئه المحكمه
سيؤجل
اقراها الى
الصيف القادم اي انه سيكرر القانون سيشرع
القانون ولكن عضويه اللجنه لجنه اختيار
القضاه سيتم تشكيلها في الصيف هذا بمثابه
ليس خط رجا بل كم مبادره حسن النيه بين
القوسين تجاه المعارضه وتجاه مبادره رئيس
الدوله ولكن هذا هو التنازل الوحيد
الذي ابدى عن استعداده
تقديمه
في الظرف الحالي ولكن ابتداء اعتقد ان
التطور الخطير هو الدعوه الى التئام
اجتماع هيئه الاركان العامه صباح غدا
قررت رئاسه هيئه الاركان العامه للقوات
الاسرائيليه ستجتمع صباح غدا وذلك وفقا
لخبر اجزاءه التلفزيون الاسرائيلي والكره
الاولى وهو ستلتقي يلتهم غدا لمناقشه
تداعيات
التطورات الامنيه في بوعيده استقاله او
اقاله وزير الدفاع اعتقد بان هذا الامر هو
بمثابه اجراء عادي خاصه وان هيئه الاركان
العامه تجتمعوا عاده اهي فيه صبيحه كل يوم
اثنين
اسبوعيا ولذلك هذا ربما تصاميم وتصادف مع
التطورات الامور ولكن لم تقول الان بان
هذا هذا اجراء روتيني وقبل قليل قلت لي
هذا امر خطير لماذا اعتبرته خطير ولكن هذا
تجامل بعد تطورات الاخيره خاصه في هدوء
المعلومات عن تردي الاوضاع الامنيه على
جميع
وايضا
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الاخيره التي
تؤكد بان ايران تسعى الى توحيد الجبهات
المختلفه لانتهاز الفرصه وما يدور داخل
اسرائيل لشن هجوم او تصعيد التوتر الامني
حول حدود اسرائيل المختلفه
دكتور مئير من ابرز
الخطوره الاكبر الان حسب المراقبين وحسب
الداخل الاسرائيلي هو الموضوع الامني
والان نحن امام عصيان عسكري ايضا ما مدى
خطوره ذلك وما هو سقفه
نعم اوه في الواقع انا اعتقد انه الحديث
عن عصيان عسكري هو مبكر نوعا ما ذكرتها هو
انه كل الخطوات التي اتت حتى هذه اللحظه
هي اتت في اطار الشرعيه والحديث هو على
عدد قليل ولكن لا شك في انه لو استمر
الامر على هذه الوتيره فهذا قد يمثل خطوره
اريد ايضا ان بانه السيد هو العسكري
الوحيد ليس فقط على قائمه الليكود وانما
في على قائمه الائتلاف اقصد العسكري الذي
كان لديه يعني برتبه برتبه برتبه لواء
اركان في الجيش
وطالما تباها به الليكود وبالتالي سوف
يكون من
الصعب ان يجد الليكود شخص اخر مكانه
واعتقد انه قد يحتفظ لنفذ لسيدنا نتنياهو
بمنصب بنفسه كما حدث في الماضي وكما هو
متعارف عليه في اسرائيل في في مراحل عديده
ولكن انا اريد ان اقول هنا انه لا شك في
انه تغيير وزير الدفاع في المرحله محوريه
التي تعيش اسرائيل اليوم حرب على الارهاب
من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى المواجهه الوشيكه
مع النظام الايراني هو ليس بالشيء السهم
وليس
معي دكتور مائيه يقول ما يجري في اسرائيل
سيؤثر على امنها وجيشها يعني حتى الولايات
المتحده تقول بان ما يجري على الارض في
اسرائيل سيؤثر على امنها وعلى جيشها
ساعود اعود اليكما ولكن قبل ان اذهب الى
عيال عليمه ساذهب الى زميلنا زياد حلبي
زياد ماذا لدينا من جديد هل هناك من ردود
افعال جديده هل هناك من تصريحات جديده
حاليا ان الشرطه الاسرائيليه استخدمت
المياه العادمه في محاوله ابعاد المحتجين
عن منزل نتنياهو في اطار الاحتجاجات
المتواصله على ليس فقط على اقاله جالنت
وانما في اطار الاحتجاجات القائمه على خطه
نتنياهو ايضا رؤساء الجامعات وخاصه جامعات
البحوث اعلنوا بان الجماعات ستبدا اضرابات
وعدد ايضا من الاطباء في بعض المستشفيات
اعلنوا بانهم سيقدون اضرابا ولهذا هناك
اهميه لما قاله رئيس النقابات العماليه في
اسرائيل بانه سيكون لديه بيان غدا بامكان
هذا الرجل عمليا ان يشل اسرائيل تماما ان
هو اقدم على اضرابات في المؤسسات وفي
المرافق الاسرائيليه المختلفه
ليتكامل ذلك مع الاحتجاجات على الارض بهذا
قد يصبح
بنيامين نتنياهو الحكومه امام ورطه حقيقيه
في الايام
المقبله المتوقع فعليا ان تبدا عمليه
التشريع ربما غدا او بعد غدا
للتعديل القانون قانون القضاء بالنسبه
للائتلاف الحكومي طبعا تتوالى الاحاديث من
اركان المعارضه اساسا ومن بعض نواب الكود
الذين يتحدثون للاعلام الاسرائيلي في في
محاوله الدفاع عن قرار بنيامين نتنياهو
شكرا لك زياد حتى الان ساذهب الان الى
عيال عليمه المحلل العسكري الاسرائيلي سيد
ايال الان البيت الابيض يقول ما يجري في
اسرائيل سيؤثر على امنها وعلى جيشها
وقال البيت الابيض ايضا بان الولايات
المتحده قلقا ما يجري في اسرائيل بعد
اقاله وزير الدفاع هذه الخطوه هذه الاقاله
هذا التمسك بالتعديلات القضائيه سيد ايال
كيف سيؤثر حقيقه على امن وجيش اسرائيل
وخاصه بانه يحكي عن اوسيان عسكري
اولا قضيه العصيان العسكري ليست قضيه
افتراضيه في الواقع راينا ان هذه الموجه
قد بدات في صفوف قوات الاحتياط وتتوسع
ايضا الى الجيش
الالزامي والنظامي وهذه ليست افتراضات انا
اطرحها وانما وزير الدفاع قال ذلك بشكل
واضح ومباشر اليوم مصدر امني عقبه
واعطى بعض التفاصيل الخاصه بهذا الموضوع
هذا الامر لما يكن افتراضيا وانما
هذا التفكك الذي بدا في صفوفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي اصبح حقيقه هنا
هو حكومته يتحملون هذه المسؤوليه يتحملون
اي ثغره امنيه من الممكن ان تحصل في
اسرائيل
بلا شك في الواقع باعتقادي ما نراه اليوم
في الشوارع الاسرائيليه هذه الموجه
المفاجئه من المظاهرات
التلقائيه دون اي اي مخطط بعد الاعلان عن
اقاله وزير الدفاع ربما تدل على بدايه نوع
من فقدان السيطره اذا كانت حتى الان
المظاهرات منظمه وكانت معروفه ومخطط لها
هذه هذا المساء نتحدث عن خروج الجماهير
الالاف الى الشوارع الاسرائيليه ربما نوع
من ولم يكن من المبالغ فيه لو قلنا نوع من
بدايه الثوره الداخليه اقاله وزير الدفاع
كانت بمثابه ربما خط احمر نحن نعلم ان
القضايا او المواضيع الامنيه والعسكريه
تعتبر قضايا مقدسه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي
انت تؤكد على ما تقوله المعارضه
الاسرائيليه بان نتنياهو تجاوز الخط
الاحمر
صحيح الحقيقه بانه بانه
توصيات وما قاله وزير الدفاع الوزير الذي
عينه نتنياهو نفسه رفض هذه التوصيات وبدلا
من تبني هذه المواقف وهذه الاصوات التي
وضع مواقف المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه قام
باقالته هذا كان ربما مؤشر بان نتنياهو في
المضيء قدما في هذه الطريقه المسيره التي
قادر الان ان يقنع نتنياهو بان يتراجع
ويتنازل عن موضوع التعديلات القضائيه يعني
لا اعرف بالنسبه لاقاله وزير الدفاع اذا
قادر على ان يتراجع عن هذا الموضوع وخاصه
بانه حسب زميلنا زياد بانه يبدو بانه ايضا
وزير الدفاع حسب هناك معلومات تتحدث ليس
هناك شيء مؤكد بانه سيقدم التماسا او ما
شابه يعني هناك سيكون
تصعيد كبير على كافه الجهات الارض الامن
ازمه دستوريه من الممكن ان تحل ايضا
باسرائيل الان الجيش الاسرائيلي كيف يجب
ان يتعاطى مع هذا الامر
اولا قبل قليل نفى وزير الدفاع انه ينوي
الالتماس الى محكمه العدل وقال ان هذه
الاشاعات التي روجت غير صحيحه اصدر بياننا
بهذا الموضوع ولكن بغض النظر عن هذه
القضيه لا شك ان الصعيد امام موقف حساسه
للغايه ليس فقط
من عسكريه والامنيه والاقتصاديه والداخليه
ما نراه ربما مره اخرى يدل على نوع من
الانقلاب الداخلي في هذه المرحله لا اعتقد
ان نتنياهو قد يتراجع عن نيته
التوجه الى التعديلات او الانقلاب القضائي
ولكن في الواقع ما بدا كانقلاب فضائح تحول
الى انقلاب في النظام الحاكم وهذا ما نراه
ما تقوله خطير جدا نعم تقول انقلاب في
النظام ماذا تقصد بذلك يعني اشرح لنا مما
تتخوف
الحقيقه اشرتم قبل قليل بان نقابه
نقابه العمال في اسرائيل اعلنت غدا عن
اطار شامل كذلك نقابات مختلفه الجامعات كل
المؤسسات العسكريه في حاله من الشل واذا
ما كانت هناك علامات استفهامه خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره ربما ما رايناه خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره
حجاجات كانت وسيله لاقناع الحكومه للتراجع
عن نيتها عن الخطه التي عرضتها عنها
الانقلاب القضائي ولكن يبدو لي انه بعد
اقاله وزير الدفاع اصبح واضح انا بان هذه
الحكومه لا تنوي التراجع ولذلك
الطريقه الوحيده امام المجتمع الاسرائيلي
كما يراه
وربما الدليل اليوم مساء اليوم في الشوارع
وفي المدن الايساليه حيث يخرج او الجماهير
الى
الشوارع دون اي توجيهات او تعليمات مسبقه
هذا يدل على خطوره الوضع الذي تعيشه الى
امامه ازمه حقيقيه ليس اقل من ذلك سيد
عيال ساذهب مجددا الى دكتور مصري دكتور
يقير
هل يمكن ان نعتبر بان ما تشهده اسرائيل
هذه الايام وفي هذه الساعات تحديدا هو غير
مسبوق
نعم اعتقد انه غير مزبوط اذا تحدثنا عن
المظاهرات فهذا مزبوط عرفت اسرائيل
المظاهرات حاشده عند الانسحاب من قطاع غزه
نظم اليمين انذاك بمظاهرات حاشده
ضد حكومه شارون انذاك وكذلك في مراحل
سابقه عند الانسحاب من سيناء وفقا لاتفاق
معاهده السلام مع مع مصر ولكن
هل ما يجري من احتياجات من مواقف من تعنت
من قبل حكومه نتانياهو يعني الان سيد اياد
يقول بانه هذا انقلاب على النظام هل شهدت
اسرائيل مثل هذه الازمه سابقا نعم
في اثناء عمليه اوسلو التي ادت الى اغتيال
رئيس الوزراء الراحه لاسحاق رابين وكان
هناك عنف في الشوارع وتحريض على الكراهيه
وعلى العنب وتحريض وصلوات
لموت رئيس الوزراء وفيما بعد تم اغتياله
في هذا في على ضوء هذا هذا الحجم ولكن
الشيء الذي هو غير مضبوط غير مزبوط ليس
المظاهرات ليس الاراده الشارع او المعارضه
وانما ما هو غير مسبوق هو الصدام القائم
بين الحكومه والدوله ان الحكومه اليوم كما
ذكرت لم تعد في مواجهه مع المعارضه او مع
الشارع وانما مع مؤسسات الدوله مع القضاء
مع الجيش مع الشرطه وهذا
من سيحل هذه الازمه
انا اعتقد انه ان هناك هناك خياران ليس
ليس لهما الخيار الاول هو ان
يرضخ السيد نتنياهو الى صوت الشارع والى
المؤسسات القضاء والى الرئيس ويبدا في
حوار جاد مع المعارضه اعتقد ان وانا اعتقد
ان هناك فرصه حقيقيه بان يحدث هذا والخيار
الثاني هو ان يستمر في عناده
وبالتالي ما سوف يحدث هو انه في نهايه
المطاف وفي مرحله ما سوف يتم عزل رئيس
الوزراء انا اعتقد انه المحكمه العليا لن
تكون صامته حتى هذه اللحظه المحكمه العليا
لا يمكن ان تقر بعد الدستوريه مشروع
القانون لانه لم يمرر بعد يعني يجب ان تتم
القراءه
وتتدخل المحكمه العليا
بعد القراءه الثالثه بعد ان مرحله دخول
بدايه بدايه التوقيع على مشروع القانون
يجب ان يوقع من قبل
وزير الوزاره المعنيه بتنفيزه وزير العدل
يجب ان يوقع من قبل رئيس الوزراء ورئيس
الكنيست ورئيس الدوله ورئيس الدوله طبعا
لن يوافق على التلقيح لانه سوف يقول انه
غسوري بموجب المحكمه العليا بعد ذلك
المحكمه العليا سوف تطعن في دستوريه
المشروع وبالتالي المشروع لن يتم الموافقه
عليه لا من المحكمه العليا ولا من رئيس
الدوله وهل سوف حينئذ الخيار سوف يكون او
ان يمرر بالقوه كما يقول وزير العدل سيد
الذين يقول سوف نمرره بالقوه حتى لو قامت
بالقوه يعني هل الامور تتجه الى العنف هل
هذا اقرار منه بانهم سيتجه الى العنف لا
بالقوه بالقوه بمعنى سوف يدخل حيز التنفيذ
بمعنى تقليل صلاحيات المحكمه حيث التنفيذ
بدون اذن من المحكمه العليا وهنا المحكمه
العليا سوف تكون هذا غير دستوري
وربما يكون هناك
كما كما ذكرت بدايه بدايه
على ارض الواقع منها عزل الرئيس الوزراء
ربما
الحل الحكومه وهذه سوف تكون سابقه الحكومه
تحل من قبل او هي تحل نفسها او تحل من قبل
الكنيست ولكن لم تحل حتى هذه اللحظه من
قبل القضاء هذه هذا لم يحدث في تاريخ
اسرائيل وعندما تتوقع انهم من الممكن ان
يحدث ذلك بسبب هذه الازمه نعم ولكن انا
انا مازلت اعتقد ان السيده حتى اللحظه
الاخيره او قبل اللحظه الاخيره سوف يرضق
في نهايه المطاف لانه اذهب الى السيد
وسينتهي وقتي سنذهب الى سيد سلومه ولكن
نعود ونذكر بعض الاخبار العاجله طبعا هذه
مواقف البيت الابيض كنا تحدثنا عنها بانها
تقول ما يجري في اسرائيل سيؤثر على امنها
وجيشها ولكن اعضاء في ائتلاف نتنياهو ايضا
منذ قليل تبعنا على شاشه العربيه يقولون
بانه ارتكب خطا استراتيجيا باقاله وزير
الدفاع سيد سل ومو ماذا سيحل بائتلاف
نتنياهو هل نتوقع بان يتفكك بعد هذه
الازمه وما وصلت الامور اليه في اسرائيل
اذا تراجع نتنياهو فان هذا بالطبيعي سيؤدي
الى انفكاك وسقوط الحكومه لان العنصر
الرئيسي في هذا الائتلاف هو الاحزاب
اليمينيه والمتدينه التي تؤيد بصوره قطعيه
المشاريع الاصلاح وانها ترى بها الاساس
والهدف المرجو لاقامه مثل هذه الحكومه ففي
حال تراجع نتنياهو فانه سيقود
القاعده لتشكيل هذه الحكومه اي انه سيبدا
بالانسحاب واعتقد ان
عندها ستسقط الحكومه
بنفسها من داخلها لانه
المعارضه قائمه في حال
التنازل
مشهد على ذلك واثبات على ذلك هو دعوه
الى اقاله وزير الدفاع وهذا ما شاهدناه
مساء اليوم اي العنصر اليميني المتطرف
داخل الحكومه هو المسيطر على نتنياهو هو
المسيطر على القرار الذي قد يتخذه نتنياهو
بالنسبه لاداره الامور بالنسبه
للاصلاح القضائي فلذلك اعتقد بانه لا خط
رجع لنتنيوب فيما يتعلق
بالاصلاح
لانه في حال انسحابه هو سيكون الضحيه
الاولى لدسر هذا القران ولكن اذا بقي ايضا
هل يتحمل مسؤوليه ما يمكن ان يجري في
اسرائيل وخاصه بانه هناك تخوفات من على
امن اسرائيل وتخوفات على جيش اسرائيل هناك
عصيان عسكري وهذا سيضعف من اسرائيل التي
هي ما زالت في مواجهه مع مع ايران بشكل
كبير
[موسيقى]
معروف كاسياسي محنك ومعروف بانه ترجماته
واقعي ولكن للاسف الشديد لا احد ممكن
يتوقع ماذا سيتخذهم من قرار بين الفينه
والاخرى ولذلك اعتقد بانني سامتنع عن
التنبؤ عن تصرفات
خاصه في الضوء الظروف المتغيره والتي لا
اذا حتى الان لم يتخذ القرار المناسب
بالرغم من التحريرات الداخليه والخارجيه
بالنسبه له وليمه يراها من تداعيات سلبيه
على مكانه اسرائيل الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والدوريه اعتقد بان نتنياهو او ربما ربما
في اخر لحظه سيتخذ القرار المناسب ولكن
للاسف الشديد حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتخذ بل
مصر على موقفها طيب سيد سلومه هل من
الحلفاء او الاصدقاء وخاصه مثلا الول ايات
المتحده الامريكيه هل من الممكن ان تستطيع
الضغط على نتنياهو لايقاف ما يجري من
تطورات ومن تصعيد في اسرائيل
استبعد ذلك لانه بعد ما استمع اليه في كل
من روما وبرلين ولندن وايضا في المحادثه
المكالمه الهاتفيه المطوره بين رئيس بايدن
وبين نتنياهو ولم يستخلص العبر بل يسير
بصوره جديه ويمضي قدما ويسر ويعلن عنه عن
اصراره على
المضي في ما هو مخطط له فاعتقد ليس هناك
اي قوه خارجيه ممكن تقنعه الا في اسرته
الداخليه اعتقد بان الشيء الوحيد الذي
يمكن ان
يضمن لنتنياهو وايضا لدوله اسرائيل مخرجا
من الازمه هو ان يضمن له
حصانه بالنسبه لمستقبل المحاكمه اي اتفاق
يضمن له ان لا يعاقب لا يتم سجنه او
التجربه ولذلك في حال التوصل الى مثل هذا
الاتفاق اعتقد ان نتنياهو
سيتنحى شخصيا
وادى ايضا
ربما سيكون له حليف في قياده دوله اسرائيل
يعني على كل حال نحن نتحدث معك سيد شلومو
كنا نتابع
اعتقال لمحتاج كان ضمن هذه الاحتياجات في
اسرائيل
والاعداد ما زالت تتزايد في هذه الساحات
كان هناك ايضا من اخبار عجلات يبدو بانه
ايضا العنف يعني ايضا الان هناك متظاهره
فتاه
تتعرض ايضا
للاعتقال يتم الحديث معها الان وهناك
محاوله
لجرها خارج يبدو
الاحتياجات الى
الى مكان يبدو بانه تم اعتقالها الان تم
توقيفها الان من قبل
القوات الامنيه الشرطه يبدو بانها اعتقلت
هذه الفتاه نتابعها الان على شاشه العربيه
وكنا قبل قليل تابعنا صوره لاعتقال شاب
قبل هناك يبدو بان هناك موجه اعتقالاتنا
حتى الان نشاهد ثلاثه اشخاص تم توقيفهم
دعونا نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
اذا هذه الاحتياجات ما زالت مستمره كانت
ايضا الاخبار العاجله تتحدث بانه المحتجين
كانوا استطاعوا ان يمروا فوق الحواجز
الامنيه وتوجهوا الى بيت نتنياهو طبعا
تمديدا باقاله وزير الدفاع سيد ايال
تابعنا الان يبدو بان هناك توقيفات حسب ما
تابعناها بهذه الصور وهناك اعتقالات الا
يؤجج الشارع اكثر فاكثر ما يحدث الان
بلا شك في الواقع اعتقالاتها كانت في
الماضي ايضا خلال المواجهات الاحتجاجات في
الاسابيع الماضيه ولكن هذه المره يبدو ان
الماضي يختلف يختلف بمعنى ان هذا الخروج
المفاجئ خروج الجماهير للشوارع
ونرى كذلك ردود الشرطه وحمله الاعتقالات
التي تقوم بها هو دليل اخر على فقدان
السيطره فقدان السيطره على الشارع
الاسرائيلي واذا اخذنا بنظر الاعتبار كل
ما يحدث الاحتجاجات
في المؤسسات المختلفه في المرافق
الاقتصاديه والصناعيه هذا دليل اخر على
التوجه الى نوع من فقدان السيطره نوع من
توسع الازمه التي رايناها انا شخصيا لا
اعتقد بان نتنياهو سوف او ينوي عن هذا
القرار كانت لديه فرص مختلفه طوال
الاسابيع الماضيه ربما القرار اليوم
باقاله وزير الدفاع كان الدليل هذا ما
اعطى الشارع الاسرائيلي الضوء الاخضر
للخروجه هذا ما جعله يضرك بان نتنياهو
مصره على المضيه في هذه الطريقه ولذلك هذا
نراه لا تقدرين نتنياهو في هذه المرحله
على الاقل في حاله التراجع وربما ما نراه
خلال الخط القريبه لا اريد التنبؤ ولكن
استمرار هذه
العمليه هذه
الفقدان السيطره في الشارع وربما تجزعزع
كل القيم وكل المبادئ النظاميه في اسرائيل
يعني تعقيبا على كلامك عيال عليمه ساذهب
الى دكتور مصري هل اسرائيل ستك ون امام
مشهد ديكتاتوريه مقنعه بالديمقراطيه
لا انا لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان الحديث عن
ديكتاتوريه هو مبالغ فيه الى حد كبير لا
احد يطعن في شرعيه وفي شرعيه في نزاهه
الانتخابات التي اتت به الى صله الحكم
لهذا هناك حديث عن انه يختلف النظام اللي
يتغير النظام الانتخابي ولكن ولكن لا شك
في انه الاجراءات المتبعه وهذه المشاريع
القوانين ان دخلت حيز التنفيذ وانورت اصلا
في الكنيسه فسوف يضعف هذا من الديمقراطيه
حيث انه ينسف مبدا الفصل بين السلطات لانه
السلطه القضائيه في اسرائيل هي هي التي
تحد وتحجن من دور الاغلبيه وهذا هو عوف
متبع في كل دول العالم وهي كذلك السلطه
المستقله التي تقر بدستوريات او بعدم
دستوريات مشاريع القوانين
الاعداد هذه الاحتياجات كبرى
وايضا تحولت كما كان سيد ايايالي سماها
تحولت الى ثوره الا يفقد هو وحكومته لا شك
في ذلك انا اعتقد انه نعم لانه انا اعتقد
انه الشرعيه لا تختزل فقط في صندوق
الانتقاليه صحيح ان هناك انتخابات ولكن
الديمقراطيه لا تختزل في عمليه الاعلاميه
الانتخابيه هناك الاعتصامات وتظاهرات
والاضات كل هذه هي والاستفتاءات ادوات
العمل الديمقراطي
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه ايضا
من تل ابيب كان معي المحل العسكري
الاسرائيليمه وايضا كان معنا زميلنا زياد
حلبي من القدس ومن القدس ايضا شلوموغانور
المحلل السياسي اشكركم طبعا مشاهدينا كنا
خصصنا كل اخبار الساعه لهذه الاحتياجات
وتطورات في اسرائيل في امان الله
[موسيقى]